welcome to this video playing
international lots of school days
something else yeah okay let's see okay
let's let's play the Slav talk for an
interesting line okay I'm playing along
the chip a link on Slav a line that I
have played too numerous times and
tournament chess not in the last couple
of years ago Bishop d2 interesting not
sure what exactly it is doing yeah
should I take or play Bishop played the
bishop hmm not clear to me even the even
Bishop f5 as a possibility okay let's do
that i'm not sure i could have taken as
well
hmm okay
95 maybe I need to get rid of the San
I'd as soon as possible night bd7 just
Hanks the c6 bond some cannot do that
not sure that this is a well timed what
is doing this 95 h4 business can be
interesting but if I manage to play age
5 like I just I just did I think it's
quite strange for white let's see the
problem is he does not have a natural
reply now if he takes I can even
consider to take with the rook attacking
h4 into checking you five and I don't
know ok jump just we capture
I e5 is an additional weakness okay the
question is 97 or 96 I also must take
into account sacrifices on b5 this is
clear ok I go here it's not clear to me
my wisdom just ignoring this ok I don't
don't don't mind I mean why not I just
get e 5 i'll take it ok yeah this is
certainly ok on it if it takes on before
i have to show be four ok so you should
inform yeah well anyway I'll first first
do this attacking before if he plays a
five there's even Queen takes before to
consider yeah and we get to this
position
hmm funny I come on i am i'm just i'm so
tempted by this ya need to need to do it
if I need to do that so let's see bishop
p for the eyes got Luke age three it's
got your age three years is a bit of a
problem and the screen deform ok I
probably have to do this first I am mom
okay the Queen cycle wasn't really
necessary but it's interesting now from
a practical point of view this was
really insane to do but okay if I don't
secre Queen and probably just winning
easily but um this is this is an
interesting way to play this is
threatening a number of things mostly
Roxy to
of course I'd like to just castle and
get the last piece into play
yeah I was just wondering about this
move hmm
93 maybe and I can probably just sack
the Queen bag
hmm
yeah I should have should have just
played a normal move idiotic not the
screen sec I didn't see a direct win so
I just retreat him okay come on let's
see it's still not not clear at all I
mean this is quite obvious I have
compensation here but it's just it
wasn't necessary to to do that ok well
now group takes us three looks very very
dangerous now you can always try to give
it back it should be 4i had Bishop
before check check ok yeah well I can I
can win the Queen back but do I want
that is the question ok i want all
pieces in play
especially any Denis this rock to play
threatening rugby form
check
time morning mm-hmm Kim to threat
look the main threat yeah and I real
issue is time with your ticket not a
game no this is so useless really
useless I could have come on black
resigned yeah this is again that I
completely lost on my own I mean I can I
can probably play any move instead of
this bloody Queen sec the Queen sec is
probably winning as well but Queen B 7
is minus 3 okay but let's check just
probably in win as well so just then
probably i can choose one of one of many
wins and didn't didn't find it around
here i cannot believe it china stoom ok
ok champion in fact is this f5 wind snow
yeah this is this it is tricky it is
tricky the other thing is I'm just a
complete idiot yeah you want to play
want to look good with this bloody Queen
second it's just idiotic to do because
after Queen B 7 he just resides and it's
it's simply over a threatened Bishop
takes before if we move the night I play
d4 and it explodes I mean of colossal
explores because it plays h4 g4 and the
ton of completely nonsensical moves ah
idiotic simply geotech just think a
couple of seconds and play this and it's
over you can play look a for this is the
best move according to the computer then
d4 and rook h3 this is the best defense
and yeah something like this it's just I
mean I'm just attacking without having
sacrificed anything in fact here check I
am material up and not materially down I
mean this is just relying on
and something to work I mean I couldn't
calculate I was just hoping that it
would work and yeah well I can always
will the Queen back but it's not I saw I
saw that of course but I thought it's
not really helping yeah now the computer
gives gives me a pretty decent edge here
probably because of the better peace
coordination and this is in fact a
serious idea yeah maybe I shall do that
but yeah it looks a bit a bit meek yeah
and here it's already fishing I mean
it's still a very very tricky position
and I got I got a winning winning 11
later here King is seven wins yeah Jack
this is all all jolly difficult when ti5
how this is check a very straightforward
check went according to the comp yeah
well here just take take it and KD for
the sruthi ATM you have this is
dangerous quite quite obviously you know
I had a straight win but already
difficult to see with little time I
thought rock before put Jane good and
probably it is good but it said strokey
yeah I took here which is the pure Bluff
I didn't see a move that really was
working 'if I've is still okay and this
is nice threatening this this counter
made it here I'm just I'm just material
down for nothing yeah it's just you
shouldn't play for for some beauty price
if you if you just have a good good
simple line and this is just just
completely complete nonsense Queen B
seven as much better and this is just
refutes white set up which really I mean
with all due respect ur h 4g for
weakening everything and then a four I
mean a for what no okay but it worked at
the end due to my idiotic play and still
cannot believe that i'll just play this
simple move all right this was a really
deserved loss thanks for watching